- Tiger King, Joe Exotic's
22-year prison sentence
for trying to kill Carole Baskin
is being vacated,
but don't worry he is
not getting out of jail.
Basically, the trial
court said that Joe Exotic
had two different plans
to kill Carole Baskin.
And as a result in his sentencing,
he got a higher sentence
than he should have
because the 10th circuit said that
you can't kill someone more than once
and all of this was part of the same plan
to kill Carole Baskin
so the amount of time
that he was actually sentenced
should be slightly less.
So he was sentenced to 22 years in jail,
that might be reduced to about
17 years in jail instead.
So Joe Exotic is not going
free, he'll be re-sentenced
so we will see him in court.